good afternoon mary robinson a great
pleasure to speak to you
again i wanted to ask you ahead of uh
g7 um the the backdrop of course
to this is is a is a year of a pandemic
in order to get anywhere on climate
change is it essential
that first a deal is reached on getting
access
for poorer nations to vaccines
it absolutely is and i think this is
under
appreciated uh i feel
very strongly that there are three
things that the g7 must do in particular
and the elders have said this
both in my letters on behalf of the
elders to each of the g7
leaders personally and our statement the
other day
uh we're saying we need to increase the
access
equitable access to vaccines um for the
agave kovacs
um promise about that um a million doses
by
first of september 2021 the 500
um million uh a billion dollars sorry
the 500 million that
biden has now said the us's bottom
pfizer is very good
that's a real step in the right
direction also
uh the who wto uh
transfer of the technology and licensing
to developing countries
or else a change in the trip's
intellectual property agreement
which biden has also accepted may be
necessary and then the third thing and
the very important thing for your
question is the climate finance um
if the voices are not able to be there
because of
the lack of access to vaccines we will
not have the urgency we need
to have a good cup in glasgow that's the
bottom line
the other backdrop to this of course is
also
the uk government's proposals to cut
foreign aid spending as a percentage of
national income should that be reversed
i think it's very sad that the u.s
law the united kingdom lost an essential
leadership
which i had praised with my irish accent
over and over
you know to put into legislation 0.7.7
was real leadership and frankly it's
never been needed more this is the wrong
time
and the wrong way especially when you
have presidency of the cop
we need to build trust with developing
countries the hundred billion dollars a
year
um of climate finance half of it going
to adaptation
has been long promised and we still
haven't got there
and meanwhile developing countries are
seeing the huge
solidarity packages that the richer
parts of the world
you know understandably want for their
citizens and are able to do
for their citizens but you know the
contrast between not able to reach the
100 billion it's becoming
an angry point and when you know the the
the presidency of cop has decided
in this year of all years to reduce what
was
leadership and that means cutting
budgets
in yemen cutting budgets in sudan
cutting budgets in syria
you know it's shocking it's cutting
budgets for education
at a time when girls have to drop out of
school another
area where the uk had been leading on
girls education
you know this is not the way you build
trust
and and actually the presidency of the
cop and i know this from paris when i
was the special envoy of the secretary
general
the presidency of the cop has to have
the trust
of developing countries if we're going
to have a successful cop
that's just the absolutely prerequisite
and you rightfully mention the hundred
billion a year which was pledged as long
ago
as 2009 it hasn't yet materialized
is it enough it's not enough
but it's a trust issue what actually is
needed
is trillions more in private sector
money and part of that
100 billion takes the risk out
and there is talk now of a possible g7
focus
on more you know real clean energy
for developing countries to take the
risk out that is really important
i know of both infrastructure projects
and nature-based projects in developing
countries that they would
like to put forward and they can't get
the financing for them
because of the risks so-called involved
if that can be
de-risked that would be hugely important
the international energy agency is
calling for an immediate
stop to any new oil gas or
coal development at the same time
there's some 400 new coal mines planned
is this a realistic goal and how do we
achieve it
i really welcomed the most recent report
of the international energy agency
for the first time aligning with the
goal that we have to
implement of staying well you know below
at or below 1.5 degrees celsius above
pre-industrial standards
and that meant as fat fatty birol
rightly said you know come on guys we
got to go there we got to get out of
fossil fuel and as quickly as possible
um this is where the real action is
i'm glad that business leaders are
stepping up as much as they are
i'm glad that courts are taking actions
against shell for example
and um that shareholders are taking
action against exxon
in shareholder meetings all of this is
contributing and investors
investors in particular have issued a
recent statement
they will not invest if you and you know
if you go the
fossil fuel route but look at what the
g7 countries are doing coming out of
recovery
only 22 percent of the
investment so far coming out of um
covert is for clean energy
only 22 that's not tolerable
what you're touching on there is that it
needs to go deeper doesn't it than uh
sort of cheerful communique at the end
of the g7 there needs to be a lot of
detail
what detail specifically would you like
to see
i want to see the g7 commit
to every country this year
in glasgow having a nationally
determined contribution which is real
worked out measurable and about um
being aligned to the 1.5 degrees so it's
yeah yes it's good to have the long-term
goal of being zero carbon and zero
emissions
by 2050 but
we're more interested in what's going to
happen in 2025 2024
2026 you know measurable just as the
vaccines have to be measurable which is
why
the elders really support the gavi
um kovacs commitment that was made
for a billion by the 1st of september
and 2 billion by mid 20
2022 not saying in a global way we will
vaccinate the whole world
that's kind of rhetoric we need
precision we need
measurement we need real uh commitment
the more the g7 can recognize their
utter
responsibility we have had a year two
years really
of you know devastation around the world
and of course it's worse for developing
countries and it's worse for
the sustainable development goals
progress in developing countries it's
worse for girls
out of school who are driven into early
child marriage it's worse for the
unemployed youth who think there's now
no hope at all
and this has to change the
responsibility is huge
and it's a g7 actual responsibility
leading to a g20 in july
of changing the dynamic in a measurable
way
so we're on course for a safe and more
equitable world
mary robinson it's been a pleasure
talking to you on sky news thank you